[Music]
hi I'm Monaco I'm a software engineer
living in the San Francisco Bay Area
aka Silicon Valley and I make youtube
videos about my life as a software
engineer
we need software engineers now more than
ever to push forward the technological
bounds to unlock the potential of
humanity and improve society we're using
technology to communicate across
geographical boundaries with loved ones
we've been reexamining ourselves and how
we relate credible and factual
information for everything from local to
global scale news and people are living
longer thanks advances in medical
technology and countless lives are being
saved from technology that has been made
to be more readily accessible and due to
the great potential of technology the
tech industry is booming but studies
have shown that there aren't nearly
enough software engineers to fill the
demand of the industry there has been a
huge effort on educating more folks on
learning how to code to fill this gap
there are tons of amazing tutorials and
books out there about the technical
aspects of being a software engineer so
I wanted to make one that talks about
the more nuanced human aspects of
succeeding as a software engineer this
new video series is called how to kick
start your career in software
engineering this series is designed for
you folks who are just starting out in
your career maybe you just graduated
from a boot camp and you're about to
start your first full time role or maybe
you just finish a degree and you're
stepping into the industry as a
full-timer starting a new career can be
super scary though and I want you to
feel confident and supported in the
first couple of months at your new job
so in this series I'm going to guide you
from your first day on the job and then
help you navigate the waters too the
first few months of your job will do
this by talking about how to have a
fruitful relationship with other people
on your team by exploring the world of
networking and by understanding how to
have a healthy relationship with your
work as a software engineer for the last
five years I've used the tips we're
going to talk about every new job I
started of course how you apply these
tips will differ based on the type of
software engineering job and what part
of the industry you work in however this
series is designed for a general
software engineering audience so I hope
that you find most of the content useful
now it's honestly not an understatement
that y'all are going to play a key part
in changing the world you have so much
say and what gets made and how it gets
made and I want you to do so well and
feel empowered to be great so I hope you
like this series and without further ado
let's freaking do this
you
[Music]